so you've heard the benefits of call web
vitals but what are we working on to
make meeting those thresholds easier
in the next 10 minutes we're going to
take a whirlwind tour of features to
help you
make your pages faster i'm jake
archibald
and this is beyond fast
first up is the css properties content
visibility and contain intrinsic size
what do these do well when you load a
page the browser tries to be smart about
how much it paints
for example it won't put effort into
drawing things that are way outside the
viewport
until you scroll towards it however the
browser has to do a load of layout work
to figure out what's inside the viewport
and what isn't this is because an
element may be at the very end of the
document
but positioned at the top or some deeply
nested element could be positioned
outside all of its parents like these
are things that css just lets you do
so to figure out the size and position
of one element you generally need to
know the layout of its siblings its
parents its parents parents their
siblings their children like
basically you need to know everything
but now
there's an easy way to avoid that let's
start with these content areas
we're going to give them a content
visibility of auto this means the
browser can skip the layout of the
children
while the container is outside the
viewport but skipping that layout means
the container loses its height
so we use contain intrinsic size to set
a fallback content size for the element
this lays the containers out as if they
had a single child that's zero pixels
wide
and 500 pixels tall now zero pixels that
might sound weird but because the
container is block level it stays full
width
while we're at it we do the same with
our smaller heading elements this time
giving them a fallback height
of 60 pixels and now when the page loads
it does a full layout for everything in
the viewport so that's the top heading
there
and that first content area but that's
it it skips the rest
making things much faster then if the
user scrolls down
the other areas of the page will be laid
out just in time
all the layout shifting you see here is
happening outside the viewports the only
thing the user might notice
is an update to the scroll bar and of
course a much faster load time
but how much faster are we talking here
well i i tested this out on the html
spec
and it took the layout time down from 50
seconds
to 400 milliseconds and that's an
amazing saving
but remember the html spec is a 12
megabyte document so
this is quite an extreme case but even
on normal sites
like you can make hundreds of
milliseconds of saving with very little
change
measure with your own content and see
the difference
that's the high level for more details
see the web.dev article that is linked
in the description
but the good news is this shipped in
chrome 85
and of course that includes the other
browsers that use a chromium engine
other browser engines are thinking about
it too in particular there's positive
signals from firefox
but using it today won't break other
browsers so your users can benefit from
it
right now okay next up is the font
metrics override descriptors now that
might sound like something captivate
card would activate to stop the
enterprise exploding
but this css feature tackles a
long-standing frustration when it comes
to text rendering
have you ever gotten your layout looking
exactly as you want it in one browser
only to try it in another and find out
the text is ever so slightly misaligned
well this is because font layout
information can come from a variety of
different places within the font itself
some fonts use all of them but use
different numbers and sometimes browsers
and operating systems disagree on which
numbers to use
thankfully a new css feature tells the
browser to ignore
all of that in favor of the font metric
overwrite actually
can we just call the meth mods like this
is supposed to be a short video
okay here are the f mods so now
for text at a given font size i can say
73
is the ascenders and 25 actually this is
a bad example because it doesn't have
any descenders
um let's go for texts
cool so 25 is the descenders and finally
two percent is shared between the gaps
at the top and the bottom
and now this will be fully consistent in
all browsers that support f mods
which is currently chrome 87 but wait
what does this have to do with web files
well
the quickest way to get text on the
screen is to display it using a fallback
font straight away
and then swap to the web font once it's
downloaded
but different metrics between the fonts
can cause a massive layout jump when the
swap happens
we can fix this with f mods by adjusting
the metrics of the fallback font we can
reduce the change in layout
caused by the font swap like i said
this is in chrome 87 see the description
for more information
and links to demos we also want to find
ways to handle other differences between
fallback fonts like
different letter widths but we'll talk
more about that when things are more
concrete
okay next feature ever been browsing
around the web reading a really
interesting article
seen the link clicked it and thought
yeah okay
but i want to go back to the article
well meet
the back button okay we've had that from
the start
but it used to involve reloading the
previous page from scratch
okay that was still pretty fast and
that's actually because i optimized my
site really well
and it's a really simple site but you
can still see the problem here
this bit of the page is enhanced with
javascript and when we go back
you can see it having to reload and
re-execute
if the page involves a lot more
javascript it'll take longer the layout
may even shift around as elements are
added to the page
but let's try that again in the latest
chrome
as before i follow the link but this
time chrome automatically keeps the
previous page
in memory but it's frozen to stop it
processing and monitoring in the
background
this means when we navigate back it's
ready
instantly and that's in chrome 86
on android for cross origin navigations
and chrome 87 for same origin
navigations
this is also a gradual rollout so not
all users will get the feature at once
also it's worth mentioning that this
feature has been in other browsers such
as
firefox safari and even internet
explorer for years now
it's been difficult for us to integrate
into chrome's strict multi-process
architecture
and let's just say in this instance
we've been fashionably late there are
some gotchas too
using particular web features prevents
this optimization
and this list differs between browsers
and browser versions
in many cases you can work around it by
deactivating the feature just before the
user navigates away
using the page hide event and
reactivating it when they navigate back
using the page show event check the link
in the description for
all of those terms and conditions i
guess all right
next up it's portals portals are a new
html element that lets you load a page
and render it inside the current page
here's one i've scaled it down a bit and
given it a border
okay i know what you're thinking this is
iframes
but it's not the same for instance
portals aren't interactive
if a user clicks this they're clicking
the portal element not the page inside
the portal
okay i know what you're thinking this is
iframes
but worse however portals come with
their own advantages
for one they can be activated either by
clicking them or calling this method
when a portal is activated it becomes
the top level page
that as usual changes the url bar
it's similar to a regular navigation
except we had the page pre-rendered
ready to go so it was really really fast
but let's try that again
and rather than have the port all
setting clumsily in the middle of the
page we'll move it out of view
and wait for the user to click the
article link
when they do that we'll animate the
portal then activate it
with a little clipping and coordination
we can use this to create rather
pleasant navigation transitions
but that's not all check this out this
is the same page as before but i've
added a button
to share the article with an external
service the user clicks it
and confirms they want to share it and
that's it
but what actually happened there let's
run through that again
but with code first up the user taps the
share button
the article site creates a portal to the
sharing service then adds it to the page
and activates it now example.com is in
charge the url has changed
but the user doesn't see this blank page
because example.com uses the portal
activate event
to get a portal to the previous page and
adds it to the document
to make it clear it isn't interactive
they blur it and add their own ui over
the top although it looks like a model
on top of the article the sharing
service is in full control here
they can trust interactions with this
dialog and the user
they can confirm that from the url bar
they know who they're dealing with now
the user clicks yes
and the sharing service captures that
event uses animations to bring the
article back into focus
and then activates the portal to the
article and that gives it control of the
tab once again
you can see the url has changed
not only can portals create navigation
transitions they can create flowing user
interactions between sites
and that's in chrome behind a flag which
flag is it behind
well we might change that between me
recording this
and it going on youtube so um see the
description for details
and links to more information like we're
really interested in feedback on this
feature
uh it's fair to say we've been talking
about portals as a new thing for a
couple of years now but we really want
to get this right
especially in terms of privacy for
instance
when one site contains an iframe to
another site browsers are moving to a
model where the embedded site won't have
access to its standard set of cookies
and other storage
this prevents the two sites exchanging
information about you so it's a privacy
win
of course chrome will provide the same
protection when it comes to portals
but there's an extra challenge here if
that portal activates
it's now the top level page so it no
longer needs those storage restrictions
we need to figure out the best way to
handle this so the site can react to the
change in storage and update its content
now it has access to things like login
state and user preferences
solving this problem will also let us do
more with page prefetching and
pre-rendering across sites
in a privacy preserving way check the
description for more details on that
in fact instead of thinking of portals
as different iframes you could say
they're more like pre-render tags that
you can display
okay that's the future but what about
the present
often the quickest and easiest way to
improve the performance of your page is
to ensure
important content loads early the
preload and prefetch tags do this
and they're well supported enhancements
we also have the quick link library
which automates prefetching content
that's likely to be needed in the next
navigation
newegg used this and they saw a 50
increase in conversions
and page navigations that were four
times faster i mean that's huge
see the description for links to the
library and more information on prefetch
and preload
and that's everything i wanted to show
you today like i said
bit of a whirlwind tour i don't know if
i've mentioned the links in the
description yet
but there are links in the description
to further information
about these topics so if you're
interested in further information about
these topics and you like clicking links
in descriptions
be sure to click the links found in the
description to further information about
these topics
where are these links i hear you ask
they're in the description what kind of
information is in these links
further information what should you do
with these things well they're not going
to click themselves are they so go on
give them a click
[Music]
you